Mike's with us in Portland Oregon hey
Mike how are you better than I deserve
gave yourself just the same sir how can
I help my wife has a problem where she's
over spins every month I talked to her
she says he's trying she's starring I
forgive early saying try again next
month
and again she overspent what is she
overspending I don't buying stuff for
the kids stuff that they don't really
need buying stuff for her like one new
clothes makeup stuff for the bathroom
shelves and whatnot
I mean it's stuff that we need but we
don't need right now and we don't have
the money for right now mm-hmm so what
is your only way or not what's your
household income together we make about
$5,500 a month what do you do for a
living I'm a electronics technician at a
semiconductor facility okay all right
and how long have you guys been married
almost two years okay there's a couple
things going on one is she's
overspending two is you're an
unbelievable tightwad isn't that right
isn't that right no I've been very
forgiving of her by no no no I didn't
ask you to forgive her I asked you I
didn't need forgiving she bought food
for her kids you're you're you're you're
just like me I mean my wife is is is a
tightwad like that I'm a become a
tightwad and so I admire you for that
Mike but you are a very detailed person
who likes the rules and follows the
rules and she's not you're the nerd
she's the free spirit at your house and
I'm the free spirit at my house I mean
my wife is the free spirit at my house
I'm the nerd I'm the control guy I can't
stand it when people break the rules you
know I'm talking about yeah yeah and so
what we've got to do is you need to
lighten up a couple of these categories
and give her a little bit more wiggle
room and in return get a new promise
from her that she's gonna stand that I
think you've got these budget categories
too tight and I don't know what they are
you notice I hadn't even asked you but
I've been doing this a long time and I
can smell a super nerd and I'm one so
you and me we're cut out the same cloth
brother it's a good it's good news
because you're good at details and
you're good at keeping people in the
lanes but sometimes people like you and
me are hard to live with so I just want
you to loosen up a little bit on the
categories and and I want her vote in
the budget committee meeting when y'all
sit down to do the budget I want her to
look at the numbers and I want her vote
to count more than it has been counting
it's print pretty much like that I think
she he go ahead um she over spends the
month we made fifty five thousand but we
spend fifty seven I got that part
okay I'm not saying I think there's some
other stuff that you guys probably can
can move around and I want the budget to
be a zero based budget and I want the
two of you working on it together
I want her vote to count and then when
the here's what happens and this will
help because the way your mind works the
way my mind works is when we do that
budget it's over that's it you should do
that shut up do that and the way her
mind works is that's a general guideline
and that doesn't work it doesn't work
the budget falls apart when she does
that she screws up the budget so what
she's got to grasp at the time you all
finish your budget committee meeting the
kids are in bed you're sitting there
looking at the details of the budget
you've got to say okay that baby girl
the reason I get so upset is the way my
mind works is this is a contract and so
we're gonna pinky swear and spit shake
right now and we're gonna sign our name
in blood at the bottom of this and this
is a contract do not I promise you I
will not spend anything that is not on
this budget and if
you spend anything that is not on this
budget that's like you lying to me we
can't do that anymore unless we sit down
and talk about it because my head's
gonna explode I can't deal with it and
so that's what's going on but then as a
part of that you've gotta loosen up a
couple of these categories and let her
have some room to run this household
because you are a super nerd no doubt
about it dude and it's a good thing not
making fun of you I'm one of you but
you've gotta you got to understand how
that other person is ticking in order to
get agreement in this household this is
the Dave Ramsey show